what was going on the moment tiger woods
lost control of his
suv there are still so many questions to
be answered
we have the latest details on tiger's
crash and his road to recovery
[Music]
tiger is awake responsive and recovering
after emergency surgery which included
inserting a metal rod into his leg
the 45 year old had multiple bones
sticking through his skin
his comeback well orthopedic surgeon
neil gadadra
told me it's complicated by tiger's
previous injuries
and five back surgeries once the rod and
the screws and the pins have been put in
you're looking at about six to eight
weeks for the bone to heal it's all
about the rehab
recovery rehab will tiger woods play
golf professionally again
if the fractures heal which they should
i do expect him to fully recover and
come back and play we're hearing that
tiger was on his way to a shoot with
former super bowl mvp drew brees
and chargers quarterback justin herbert
now there were no visible skid marks at
the scene but
crash investigator tim leggett tells us
that may not be significant because
tiger's luxury suv
came with a highly sensitive anti-lock
braking system
it's not like the old days where you
know if you see skid marks
then you know that the vehicle is being
braked maximally that hyundai is
equipped with a black box
we'll find out exactly what was going on
how fast the vehicle was going
so could tiger face any charges like
reckless driving
no a reckless driving charge has a lot
of elements into it this is purely an
accident
and deputies say there was no evidence
of impairment at the scene
i asked him what his name was he told me
his name was tiger and that moment i
immediately recognized him he seemed
as though he was lucid and calm on
monday the day before the crash
tiger had a shoot with nba great dwayne
wade
i woke up today so proud to be able to
post that moment you know for the world
how good am i or how bad am i good
and i took a nap and i woke up and you
know i woke up to the news
i hopefully get a chance to get back to
doing what he loves to do and that's
playing a game of golf